WE CANNOT AFFORD CLIMATE
ACTION.
COULD THERE BE A STATEMENT
THAT IS AS STUPID OR SHALLOW
OR CYNICAL AND FALL SAYS T
ONE?
THE OCEAN WAS NOT LITERALLY ON
FIRE THE GAS ELITE FROM A
PIPELINE WAS ON FIRE IT WAS
PUT OUT AND CLEANED UP IN
HOURS.
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT SO WHY DID
HE LIE AND SUGGEST CLIMATE
CHANGE WAS THE CULPRIT AND
CLIMATE ACTION IS THE ANSWER?
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRATS
DO.
THEY LIE ABOUT CLIMATE ALL THE
TIME.
TO BE CLEAR THAT'S NOT DENYING
THE REALITY OF CLIMATE CHANGE
BUT THE DEMOCRATS DENY CLIMATE
CHANGE REALITY IN FAVOR OF THE
DARK CLIMATE FANTASY.
>> THE WORLD WILL END IN 12
YEARS IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> THE EXISTENTIAL THREAT.
>> IT IS AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT.
>> LESSON 12 YEARS BEFORE
THERE IS IRREPARABLE DAMAGE
DONE TO THIS COUNTRY.
STEVE: THE WORLD WILL NOT AND
IN 12 YEARS.
WE ARE NOT PHASING THE
EXISTENTIAL THREAT.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE
SCIENCE THAT SUGGEST HUMAN
LIFE WILL CEASE TO EXIST.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL BUT
CLIMATE CATASTROPHE IS FALSE.
IN 2014 THE UN PANEL PUBLISHED
REPRESENTATIVE PATHWAYS FOR
FUTURE GLOBAL WARMING.
IN THE BASIS THAT IT WAS
WILDLY UNREALISTIC.
IT ASSUMES A FIVEFOLD INCREASE
ON COAL BURNING OF TOTAL COAL
RESERVES.
AND START USING THE WORST-CASE
SCENARIO AND THEN THE
UNINHABITABLE EARTH AND THAT
IT IS NOT AS BAD AS IT WAS
LOOKING.
AND THEN CALLED ON IT TO BE
LESS ALARMIST BUT THE MEDIA
COMPLICIT.
AND THEN TO STOKE THAT SENSE
OF AN PENDING DOOM.
AND THEN ACCLIMATE OF CRISIS.
>> HIGH TEMPERATURES COULD
CREATE MORE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES.
>> THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST
BATTLES THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
>> CLIMATE EMERGENCY.
>> IT'S A LAST SHOT THIS
COUNTRY HAS TO DEAL WITH THE
CLIMATE CRISIS.
>> AND THEN AL GORE SAID WE
HAD TEN YEARS LEFT BUT WHAT
ABOUT YOU DEANGELIS CAMPING
WHO PREDICTED THE END OF THE
WORLD SEPTEMBER 6, 1994?
WHEN IT DIDN'T HAPPEN HE JUST
CHANGE THE DATE.
THE DEMOCRATIC CLIMATE CALL
TAKES A REAL ISSUE ENTRANCE
INTO FEAR MONGERING
CARICATURE.
BUT WATER SHORTAGES ARE A
MAN-MADE PROBLEM.
IN CALIFORNIA THE RESERVOIR
SYSTEM IS DESIGNED FOR
ACCLIMATE WITH FREQUENT
DROUGHTS LUNG DROUGHTS.
THE RESERVOIRS 120 PERSUADE
PERCENT OF AVERAGE FOR FIVE
YEARS.
BUT TWO YEARS LATER WE HAVE A
WATER SHORTAGE NOT BECAUSE OF
THE CLIMATE BUT THEY HAD BEEN
FLUSHING THE WATER OUT TO THE
OCEAN PROTECTING A SPECIES OF
FISH THAT HAS BARELY BEEN SEEN
FOR DECADES.
LAST YEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP
PREDICTED THIS WOULD HAPPEN
AND HERE WE ARE.
THIS WEEK TELLING CALIFORNIANS
TO CUT THEIR USE BY A
15 PERCENT AFTER HE WASTED
50 PERCENT THE LEFT BLAMED
CLIMATE CHANGE FOR WILDFIRES
THAT THEY RAVAGE THE WEST LONG
BEFORE THE RECENT RISE IN
TEMPERATURES 4 MILLION ACRES
BURNED AND SAID IT WAS TRUE
PROOF BECAUSE THE WILDFIRES
BUT BEFORE THEY ARRIVED IN
THIS AND 19th CENTURY
4 MILLION ACRES BURNED EVERY
YEAR TYPICALLY EACH INDIVIDUAL
WAS DUE TO THE NATIVE
POPULATION UNDERSTOOD NATURE
THE ACTUAL CAUSES OF THE DAVIS
DATING FIRES SWEEPING THE WEST
ARE STUPID DEMOCRATIC
POLICIES.
DECADES OF FIRE SUPPRESSION
STOPPING A NATURAL BURN
KEEPING FOREST DIVERSE AND
HEALTHY.
FAILURE TO REMOVE DEAD TREES
AND BRUSH A CATASTROPHIC
ACCUMULATION OF FUEL.
MISMANAGEMENT OF UTILITIES
LEADING TO MORE TECHNICIANS
FROM POWER LINES.
BARELY MENTIONED BY THE
LEFT-WING POLITICIANS.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PRACTICAL
STEPS YOU CAN TAKE THAT THEN
THE TWEETS CLAIMING IT ON THE
CLIMATE.
AND THEN THEY BLAME IT ON
CLIMATE THAT THEN THEY ALREADY
DID SO WHY DO THEY PUSH THE
OBVIOUS LIES?
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE THEY ADOPTED THE
TACTIC TACTIC OF MANUFACTURING
A CRISIS TO JUSTIFY A
DRACONIAN CRACKDOWN THEY KNOW
THE FACTS DON'T JUSTIFY THEIR
EXTREMIST AGENDA.
CLOSING DOWN THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY, BANNING CARS OR THE
WAY WE COOK AND THEY WANT
EVERYTHING TO RUN ON
ELECTRICITY AND WHERE DOES
THAT COME FROM?
MORE SOLAR POWER THAT CANNOT
BE ECONOMICALLY STORED HOW
CLEAN IS THAT WHEN THE PANELS
ARE MADE WITH :   SLAVE LABOR
FROM CHINA?
THEY WENT MORE WIND THAT KILLS
HALF A MILLION BIRDS PER YEAR
ON TOP OF THAT THEY WANT TO
SHUT DOWN NUCLEAR POWER WHICH
IS THE MOST RELIABLE CARBON
FREE SOURCE OF ENERGY WE'VE
GOT AND GUESS HOW THE CLAIMANT
LEADERS ARE SENDING THE GAP?
IN CALIFORNIA THEY ARE
IMPORTING OIL FROM SAUDI
ARABIA.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
THE ENTIRE ENERGY AND
ENVIRONMENT POLICY IS IDIOCY
IN CONTRADICTION NO TO
AMERICAN OIL GAS PS2 SAUDI
ARABIA NOTES AMERICA YES TO
PUTIN MAKING US MORE DEPENDENT
ON ELECTRICITY WHILE MAKING
ELECTRICITY THEN ONE - - LESS
DEPENDABLE WIRE AND THE
DEMOCRATS LAUGHED OFF THE
STAGE WHEN THEY PREACH ABOUT
CLIMATE?
NOT THE PARTY OF SCIENCE THEY
DENY SCIENCE THEY DENY SCIENCE
ON THE PANDEMIC OR LOCKDOWNS
THEY DENY SCIENCE AND KIDS IN
GENDER AND DRUG USE AND ABOVE
ALL THEY DENY SCIENCE ON
CLIMATE THEY BLAME CLIMATE
CHANGE AND PUSH POLICIES THAT
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN A BLOCK
POLICIES THAT NUCLEAR POWER
WHAT DO THEY KNOW ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT ANYWAY?
THE CLOSEST THEY HAVE EVER
COME TO NATURE IS GENDER AT
THE RAINFOREST CAFÉ WE KNOW
NATURE WE LOVE NATURE WE WANT
TO PROTECT AND PRESERVE AND
CONSERVE IT LET'S FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THE DEMOCRATS AND NOT
JUST LYING ABOUT THE ISSUES WE
CANNOT LET THEM GET AWAY WITH
IT.
A REPUBLICAN WHO JUST
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION FOR
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES AND
GOVERNOR DESANTIS WITH HIS
MILLION DOLLAR CONSERVATION
LAND BILL IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT WHO SIGNED
CONSERVATION AND LEGISLATION
IN A GENERATION BUT THEN
THERE'S GO UP PRO CONSERVATION
MARKETS OF INNOVATIO